I have been a fan a friend and in love
with this lady this wonderful lady all
of my life I just can't figure out how
she keeps getting more and more
beautiful I just get older okay baby
whatever you say we're here to introduce
present the Oscar for original song the
nominees are from the Mambo Kings
beautiful Maria of my soul music by
Robert Kraft lyric by Arnie glimmer from
Aladdin friends like me music by Alan
Menken
lyric by Howard Ashman from The
Bodyguard
I have nothing music by David Foster
lyric by Linda Thompson from The
Bodyguard run to you music by Judd
Friedman buried by Allen ribs from
Aladdin the whole in the world music by
Alan Menken lured by Tim Rice and the
Oscar for original song goes to Alan
Menken and Tim Rice for a whole new
world from again
you
thank you very much I'd like to thank
everybody in Academy who voted for me
especially Allen and I'd like to pay
tribute to two great lyricists one of
course is Howard Ashman I'm extremely
lucky to be standing in his shoes I know
he'd be here today if he was still alive
and the other is the great Sammy Khan
who is my inspiration for many years and
it's and it's great to be working with
Allen and my thanks to everybody at
Disney a couple thanks thanks to Leia
Salonga and Brad Kane and thanks to
people Bryson and Regina Bell and of
course Walter Afanasieff and Robbie
Buchanan for creating a beautiful record
and thank you Chris Montana for never
giving up on this song thank you